one suspect is dead and another is in
custody in connection with the
disappearance of Army private first
class Vanessa Guillen the 20 year old
vanished from Fort Hood Texas in April
and on Tuesday human remains were found
about 20 miles from the base and gihon
family believes the remains are hers
Mireya Villarreal is covering this story
for us Maria good morning what more do
we know about these suspects well good
morning Tony you know the Army has been
very tight-lipped about this case but
yesterday they did reveal they had two
suspects in mind one was a soldier that
died by suicide less than a day after
those new remains were found the Guillen
family is still demanding answers that
they say they have not gotten in more
than two months the day-after remains
believed to be those of Vanessa Guillen
were found the army revealed there were
suspects early Wednesday morning army
investigators contacted Killeen police
to say one suspect in the case left his
post on base officers located the
suspect walking about six miles from
Fort Hood when police confronted the
suspect he pulled out a weapon and shot
himself the Army is not identifying him
yet the second suspect the wife of a
former soldier is in custody she has not
been identified either Vanessa Gaines
sister Lupe is angry and determined to
push Congress to investigate Fort Hood
after Vanessa's disappearance in a
statement the army said the reason for
not releasing certain information is
because doing so can seriously
jeopardize the charging and successful
prosecution of individuals but they say
they have made significant progress in
this tragic situation and are doing
everything possible to get to the truth
Guillen went missing on April 22nd some
time before that family attorney Natalie
Kiwanis Vanessa disclosed to friends
family and fellow soldiers that she was
sexually harassed on base kawaman says
vanessa was terrified of reporting it up
the chain of command if sexual
harassment was coming from her superiors
so
our concern was the retaliation being
blackballed the army says it is
investigating those allegations but as a
sister myra refuses to stop fighting
until justice has been served I still
have to lead on with making sure that my
sister gets everything that she deserves
there are a few names that are floating
around right now as possible suspects in
this case the Army is expected to hold a
press conference this afternoon where
they will release more details on the
Vanessa Guillen disappearance at the
same time the family is expected to hold
a protest in Washington DC demanding
justice for Vanessa
Anthony understand why the family's so
frustrated Mariah thank you